[Music]
space is ultimately where humanity will
find survival we will be expanding into
space and eventually it will become
second nature that is the destiny that
were pursuing we know how to get into
orbit we sort of know how to go to the
moon going to Mars is a whole nother
story and he has taken me 40 years of my
life to build an engine that can do this
[Music]
ever since I was very little I loved
space and I wanted to be an astronaut as
children in Costa Rica we would
configure our own spaceship out of
cardboard boxes and inside we put the
chairs laying on their back and we would
sit or lay down and we would countdown
to liftoff and we would go into space
and
explore distant worlds and fight a few
monsters here and there and always be
back in time for dinner
gradually as time pass I forged a game
plan to become a space explorer and a
scientist around 1967 I was 17 years old
and I wrote a letter to NASA and it was
to my surprise that I got a response
there was an underlying sentence in one
of the year paragraphs that said careers
with NASA are generally limited to u.s.
citizens I interpreted that as saying eh
come on over to the US become a US
citizen and then come to work for NASA I
didn't need any more encouragement I
went right ahead and emigrate to the
United States there were some very
difficult moments when I first arrived
in the u.s. I was 18 years old
and I came here with only $50 and I
didn't speak English and I had to go
back to high school and you know I was
really failing all of my subjects but
from the bottom you cannot go any
further down so I began to improve and
over the months I was very close to the
top of the class that was what I needed
to get in that the University of
Connecticut I entered there in 1969 and
that was the year that Neil Armstrong
landed on
when I saw that to me it was something
very personal about I felt that I was
just a little bit closer so I went to
graduate school at MIT and it was there
where I began thinking that typical
chemical rockets were going to be very
limiting in the future and that we
needed to take a paradigm shift to be
able to truly explore space and 1977 I
became a citizen and I finally applied
to NASA and that day my life changed
completely it was not until May of 1980
that I received a call saying we would
like you to join us in the ninth group
of astronauts the first thing I did is I
called my parents in Costa Rica
my father had began to cry he handed the
phone to my mother who went into orbit
our dr. sparke and science
representative Franklin chang-diaz I
have become the first naturalized
citizen from Latin America who would
become an astronaut
on my first flight we were playing on
our backs
going through the countdown and I
thought to myself I've done this before
I did it when I was a little kid in that
cardboard box and those images came back
to me in that very moment I flew in
space not one but seven times way way
more than I ever imagined while I was
training as an astronaut I really felt
that I had two jobs one was to be an
astronaut but the other one was to work
on solving the transportation problem
when you look at the present-day rockets
it's gonna take you close to seven to
eight months to get to Mars and then
you're gonna have to wait almost two
years until the lining up of the planets
happens again and you can try to jump
back this is not a fast efficient
transportation system and space can be a
harrowing horrible place when things
don't work with a plasma rocket you can
go to Mars in just over a month is
something that allows you to go there
quickly do your exploration and then
come back before Mars and the earth Gale
arranged I don't see how we could get
anywhere in space without the plasma
rocket that we are developing people
think that this is impossible but it's
not
it is difficult it's not impossible our
engine is called the VASIMR engine and
the name bassinger stands for variable
specific impulse magneto plasma rocket
many people when they come to our lab
expect to see a rocket firing they they
expect lots of rumbling lots of noise
and as none of that it's silent there
are no moving parts no explosion it is
an eerie sensation to see this plasma
coming out of this magnetic nozzle this
is almost like science fiction what you
do here is just the noise of all the
pumps that are trying to keep the vacuum
conditions of the rocket can live you
can fire this big tank is nothing but a
way for us to create the conditions of
space
when we fire this rocket in space for
real we probably will be able to see it
from the earth we will be able to light
up part of the sky we will create what
was called an artificial Aurora this is
the transportation of the future
[Music]
I guess in many ways I never grew up and
I'm still a child and I I feel that I
come to work to play my fundamental
dream now is to enable humanity to truly
be a multi-planet species it's like
going from the steam engine to you know
to the automobile today to the internal
combustion engine for me watching the
plasma engine fly would be the
fulfillment of another lifelong dream
[Music]